wenn sprüchen hier so aufgeht ja das
sieht gut aus das sieht verdammt
schlecht aus hallo ich meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge gegen fünf zusammen
mit komme warum fragt ihr euch also
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
darum weitere folgen nein das ist die
zweite folge weil die erste folge kamen
bei dem netten herrn kommen auf dem
kanal hallo hallo hallo besorgt aber na
ja und ich will etwas weiter als du und
ich habe gesagt ich will nicht roll und
der wolf effekt auch dadurch unsere
stadt schlecht sag mal komme worum
geht's hier warum heißt mehr bei bob
gale warum heißt 75 ganz einfach aus dem
grund weil hierbei den ganzen spiel
kartentypen sage ich mal aus fünf
verschiedenen spielen wie zum beispiel
portal so die karten irgendwie errichtet
worden also davon so typische elemente
wie hier auch die farben mit übernommen
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe kann
ich auch gerne korrigieren her klar also
auf jeden fall geht ich einfach direkt
weil alles was du sagst als duncan alles
scheiße einfach diese karte besteht aus
fünf parkuhren diese par kurs beinhaltet
saints row pokémon portal so ein paar
spiele ich weiß garnicht anderem zwei
ich glaube auch noch selber sondern noch
immer das gesagt oder wunderschön und
jede karte hat ja auch gesagt jede
parcours karte ist ein wenig dem spiel
angepasst also hier bei portalen wie zum
beispiel das die ganze zeit klar dass
mit uns redet auch im chat das könnt ihr
mann chris colfer den ted hoch nur viel
aus großer höhe
das wzb hier die klar dass man uns
geredet und so die ja auch im portal
vorkommt und alles ein bisschen
angepasst bei super mario weiß auch
nicht sind wir noch nicht wir sind
jedenfalls grad bei portal
wir haben uns gedacht dass diese map
eigentlich nur fünf paare gehen sollte
aber allein drei parts für ein paar
kurier braucht nicht auf und das ist
auch alles so schwer ich habe jetzt
einfach gesagt wenn ich beide also die
folgenden 15 minuten
ich hab jetzt einfach gesagt wenn ich
bei der hälfte irgendwie immer noch hier
bei dieser schein dann nehme ich mir so
ein paar tanz dich nicht sondern ich nee
also
endlich zu potte kommen soll und ich
hole mir ein paar blöcke und baue mir
einfach ein paar hilfen da wo ich nicht
weiterkommen aber konnte die sprünge
werden ja nicht besser ihr bei mir die
werden immer schwieriger habe ich das
gefühl hatte ich schaffe das hier jedes
empfiehlt mal den ein sprung hier ja
leute willkommen zum neuen endlos
projekt auf unserer beiden kanälen
wirtschaft weit farbmix com ist zwar an
die etage höher bei der reihe jetzt
läuft jetzt läuft aber gleich kommen wir
dieser mega schwierige sprung beim
sprung das also ausfahrende blöcke hier
das geht kaum weil aus fanden blogger
habe ich nicht mein problem nicht nur
mit euch in sachen wenn dann so wenn man
auf einzelne blöcke aktuell ist die
skype einfach weg das ist wunderschön
deswegen einfach mal abgestürzt das
liegt wahrscheinlich sogar mal im
internet weil die ganze liga heftiges
jetzt bin ich auch noch total über
steuert jetzt mittlerweile wenn der
kombi weggezerrt werden dreht ihm ein
ganzes aufnahme buch hat mir auf einmal
habe ich versucht das material zu kegeln
einfach gar nicht gehört soll ich mach
das mal eben so dann sollte sich jeder
alles ganz ok sein ich rufe den kommen
jetzt mal eben an aktuelle ruft hallo
und wann was war da los
eine tonqualität sehr sehr geil da geht
einfach nicht weiß
naja ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
wahrscheinlich an dem gewitter ihr
dachte ich auch gerade so eben gerade
noch drüber gesprochen so hätten den
kollegs aufnahme geht alles den bach und
ja sie sei gläubig gewitter und aldrin
an
und jetzt also gomez folge übrigens
kommt das erste volkes balkon auf dem
kanal mal ganz kurz zu gesicht sagen
hier
da haben wir schon so gesagt ja bei
kopfweh lokal bei mir ist ja wirklich
hat krasses gewitter irgendwie das ist
ja hier der mai der meile macht was man
will also nicht mehr der april seine mai
bei mir klatschen die blitze hier rein
wie die 14 aus gomez co das ist
unglaublich
seine sprüche waren aber auch schon mal
besser hier kommunalen freue mich über
so ein kompliment ich hab das jetzt ich
merke dass ich habe es nicht geschafft
ich sehe das problem muss später gucken
wegen meiner lautstärke ich glaube ich
bin inzwischen total reisetätigkeit ich
kenne das bei premiere dann mach ich das
einfach ein bisschen höher
klar war bei der regel emi hin lange
musik lauf hast dann aber ein problem
derweil an die musik so richtig laut ist
nehme ich mache musik im hintergrund
das ist ganz gut für so was eigentlich
jedenfalls ich weiß nicht vielleicht
nicht wirklich an gewitter das zurzeit
telekom probleme sind fall telekom ist
auch so scheiße bist du dann extra
wieder darunter gefallen mich zu boxen
ich versuche das kann doch nicht sein
dass ich diesen sprung ich schaffe
kommen wir da nicht mehr helfen konnte
der etage runter das waren zusammen
wenigstens fehlen ok oder ich komme
gleich einfach eine etage höher die
hälfte der folgezeit standen fast ja wir
können ja noch einmal hier bei dir
probieren
obwohl kommt zu mir ruhig kommen ich
lade war nicht ich bin hier ja da ist
jetzt erstmal erstmal auf kreativ dann
schön gegen die lava dahin gesetzt
quatsch als ob ich in creative mit war
was mache ich dann zum tode screen den
tod
ich schaffe das jetzt aber ich glaube
jetzt mal mich ja genau so läuft das
auch immer die ganze zeit und deswegen
bin ich auch so schlecht weil er komme
ich in die ganze zeit ab schiesst er
genau
ich bin jetzt profi ich bin entschuldigt
im forum steht unter den regeln für die
karte trollen so viel wie geht
ich mache mal mein trading softpro weil
jetzt sagt mir das spiel halt auch dass
ich ein problem
jetzt sollte das eigentlich alles
funktionieren alle ich hasse die sprünge
mit teleport ich bitte zu mir man dann
kannst du mal mit mir führen wie nervig
das ist wahr das ist ja jetzt kommt da
jetzt kommt der höhe die tastatur
er nimmt anlauf und eine tasche
unterlief
aber ich glaube jetzt soll ich das
schaffe ich war ich in gómez partner
auch schon da da bin ich wohl auch
gestorben
diese map map ich sage immer wenn ihr es
besser könnt macht ein video und schickt
uns dass das glaube ich nicht wenn ihr
das in einem versuch schaffte dann
kriegt ihr meine vollste aufmerksamkeit
aber also kein steht auch hier also
wieder symbolisiert jene jungs starken
runter das ist doch mal hier aber ich
bin profi wo magath seinen profi du bist
auch falsche töne
ich hoffe dass mir heute ganz kurz ruhig
hier ganz ruhig wie ich extra eine weiße
hier
richtig gegönnt er macht macht man leiht
eben da kann ich selbst läuft komme das
land eine scheiße hier
ich weiß nicht ob ich lange muss ich mal
schlau machen das geht nicht
doris ausfelder der passt nichts
bestimmen und der tür durch derzeit
breit als der türsteher breiter als 40
stehen muss man dazu sagen guck mal ich
hab sogar selbst geschafft jetzt hallo
er guckt mal und jetzt musst du hier
einer seite du bist wie creative nein
ich kann mich schlagen weil durch
teleportiert hast das ist so ein
gemeiner sprung so ein gemeiner sprung
das ist unfassbar der designer sonne
kacke hier oben ich wünsche ihm
geblieben
ich wünsche ich mir da ungewiss da haben
alle viel sympathischer und produktive
derzeit oder wo wir müssen hier
präsentieren die deutsche minecraft
szene ist das erste mal dass in
deutschland gespielt wird glaube ich
ehrlich sein aber hier ist es natürlich
klar dass ich hier lange muss dann weißt
du sooo genau man wir unseren ruf für
ganz deutschland aufrecht erhalten wie
er ist zurück in den garten livestream
auf alle möglichen plätze unter anderem
auch am brandenburger tor auch ganz groß
vom fernsehturm in düsseldorf ja und
auch grüße natürlich nach münchen und
auch in die österreicher in ihnen die
österreich auch in die auch grüße in die
schweiz nach österreich leben kiss kiss
mit köpfe da unten ja schreibt meine
kommentare wenn ihr aus schweizer
österreicher wilma interessieren weil
denn die sprecher die als sprach und mir
wurde man bei google analytics damals
angezeigt dass das schon
anderen ländern komme strumbel stromberg
09 läuft ab jetzt meine frage an dich
also erst ich bin jetzt hier musst du
jetzt ist echt zu doof nie beantwortet
ob du sagst mir aber nicht wiederholen
oh mein gott es geht nicht es geht ich
war so viel wie noch nie
doch so ok mit etwas anlauf jetzt darauf
dass meine ich da komme ich auch nie
drauf ich war da aber schon formiert
außen ist es geht nie sprintet de
doch putin ein hallo wir falls
zusammenprall schließlich noch falls
april stark ich habe von der eigenen
sache nichts mit anfangen weil ich in
creative meine güte 70 diese sprünge die
wache bekloppt
er ist besser es nur einmal glück jetzt
bin ich hier schon das kann doch nicht
sein
es wird er doch viel schwieriger alle
also bei diesem pisten bei den pisten
sprüngen wer so heftig jetzt ich glaube
ich also ein gutes gewissen
du hast du arschloch das kann doch nicht
sein ich mache ich dich schön da schon
auf das loch schon richtig schön
aufbereitet
man kommt ein arschloch oder ein
arschloch arch hat sogar das arschloch
einen arsch deswegen kurz ihr auch so
viel habe ich eine zufolge gesagt alles
für den stoff ist so geil komme ich kann
echt geschafft den sprung kann man hier
bin ich
richtung werde da ich war schon so weit
gerade wieder lebt zumindest immer
wieder ein paar schöne sprünge schöne
und tod
das kann doch nicht sein aber da stand
auch difficulty hat muss man überlegen
also die anderen karten waren glaube ich
alle so auf easy und so hoffe ich mittel
und sonst was
da fällt schon beim anfangs sprich auch
sagen ach man das ist doch der kopfball
stockwerk darunter läuft so ich dir
dürfe keine blöcke abbauen
oh mein gott jetzt liegt das ja auch
noch wegen gegen pisten cnet.com ich den
trade mit 1 loch erinnert sich jemand
ein bisschen voran ihrem aber natürlich
damit dass hier auch zum ganzen
repertoire passt mach das mal eben
hätten kannst du ohne op spielmodus
creative oder so läuft das hier was ein
rumsfeld parat auf jeden fall noch von
der hat jetzt also der bsr schrumpft vom
salat von bommel gucken man wenn man so
viele unendlich lange stunden von bild
computer brillanten edel klappt das hier
auch mensch das komisch warum hier
soviel bietet ihr ich mache die sprünge
auf ehrliche weise ich faktor
du bist so schlecht ich könnte echt
gerade anfangen mirko radkarte trainer
aus meinem meiner nase
wo steht denn jetzt hier auch gut
komm komm ich brauche die sprünge auf
gar nicht ich finde es ist wie bei den
betten schon gemütlich bleiben da kommt
man als play ist er 2004 den eisenbacher
muss aber noch nicht angeguckt kann
jetzt ich schaffe es ich bin durch aber
nicht mit den pisten beide bestens da
nicht alter der zweite pisten ist ja mal
richtig fies hauptsachen runter fallen
nämlich noch alle blöcke mit und von
überall noch mal drauf stellt das war
vor sowie will so in echt springen alle
fall so normal rot-weiß-roter von auf
dem blog doch auch auf die so völlig
entstellt das hätte man dieses eine
video von dudelsack wo die dann mit
seinem klavier
jetzt gehört einem berg runter kann ich
euch mal verliehen in der beschreibung
erstmal schön großteil in dem du leben
habe ich auch mitgeschrieben gleich mit
dem aber irgendwie zurzeit leider nicht
mehr verlinkt ich euch mal das ist sehr
sehr witzig dass genau mein humor das
einfach so abgefuckt kann ich doch immer
schicken sehr sehr witzig sehr sehr geil
muss ich mich immer daran erinnern wenn
ich irgendwie muss runter fallen geht so
ich wollte das einfach machen dass der
eine den knopf so richtig langen drückt
weiter jetzt bringt nicht viel
nein fast geschafft mit denen mit denen
mit denen habe ich hab ich gesehen ja
ich hab es auch beinahe geschafft aber
ich hab irgendwie die maus verrissen
komme ich könnte heulen
ja ich auch mann der muskelkater im arm
der tut weh tut weh ich hab so richtigen
muskelkater meiner rechten in meinem
rechten nacken
warum wenn man leichte ganze zeit hier
nicht durch pickel oder wie ich ticke
mit meinem einsprüchen hier so auf
geht's ja dass sie gut aus da sieht
verdammt schlecht aus ich hab ich
vollgas unterwegs
man musste ja die seite rein springen
beim pisten man kann ja nicht einfach
darauf diesen steinblöcken kann man
nicht man muss das ist so gemein dass
schon allein schon durch bürgerkrieg
egal wer neben wir sind von ihr euch
wieder alter was ist los hier immer
entfallen wenn man sich im fallen thema
imported das spielt man ja ganz schön
dann stelle ich wenigstens in eine
ameise weißt du sagst du mir ich bin
schlecht mehr weiß warum weil ich werde
hier von die ganze zeit mit pfeilen
bombardiert ist das der grund war hier
komme ich schaffe das gasrohr ich habe
es auch bei einer geschafft womit sich
mal zusammen hier treffen bei diesem
schalter knopf jetzt mal ohne trollen
kurz pfitzer
ich bin jetzt mal wirklich ja hallo das
würde dann hier als mal eben das ist
unglaublich der aufgespießte seinen
speckrollen dass er mal richtig ihre
wolle die zwei wachen kommen jetzt das
war ein scherz jetzt hier kommen wir mal
ein video von dir war heute eine
produktive sauerstoff kommt jetzt immer
dass er zusammen ich drücke ich drücke
drücker erst richtig super das bringt
gar nichts glaube ich erstaunt noch mal
den regeln conny drücken bringt gar
nichts das bringt doch nichts jetzt
lasst das mal ich hoffe niveau wieder
pfeile du arsch persönlich die abas
weißt du das willst du oh mein gott oh
mein gott
der letzte aber egal freude ich würde
sagen das was mit dieser episode wir
haben nichts geschafft es war einfach so
gott ich scheiße der zweite teil
natürlich wird mein video übrigens nie
aber ist wir sind ja immer kurz davor
das zu schaffen mittlerweile geht es ja
denken vielleicht drei minuten oder 20
das schafft man das komm ich mach das
jetzt doch eben dieser folge über die
mannschaft ich hab s geschafft geschafft
geschafft
ja okay wenn ich jetzt nicht schaffe
dann dürft ihr alle in die kommentare
schreiben ich beobachte dich mal komme
ist viel besser als du 111 ist begegnet
sich mal hier so ein wenig na du wenn du
ja ich weiß
ohne witz ich war hier draufklicken
einer schlacht kam maria riesch das
jetzt wir kommen hier zu wie ein profi
das macht gekommen
auch knappes ding auf jeden fall gehen
freunde sind wir heute nichts mehr ich
bin so fertig du arsch komme ich hast du
dich du wirst nie wieder aus der kammer
8 hitzkopf doch gemerkt dass ich stell
dir noch einen kuchen hin und sage dann
viel spaß in einer abteilung ja freunde
das ist das richtige was mir verdient
wird ihr beim einerseits leistung ich
würde sagen es euch trotzdem gefallen
hat las eine wertung gab
schreibt uns eure kommentare wie wir das
ganze besser angehen können irgendwie
tritt tritt tricks trips also tipps und
tricks tritt trips trips oder text ex
schülern der gosse passt den auf jeden
fall alle die nächste woche kommen
morgen bei dem ja schön geil gar nicht
gar nicht kaputt jetzt die map also was
ist denn hier kaputt
ciao leute ohne witz das war nur nur in
kreisen ein kleiner ausrutscher jemanden
als betten stehen ja noch
es ist unglaublich wie scheiß egal zu
sein was gut bis morgen